un petit marcheurs bien volontaire à six
mois il est au coeur d'un projet de
recherche comprendre le fonctionnement
de la marche sur le tout petit le thème
de la thèse d'elodie inc m
originaire de chevreuse étudiante au
siams de l'université paris saclay elle
est aujourd'hui récompensé du prix
jeunes talents l'oréal unesco
on a fait une étude longitudinale donc
on a suivi des enfants depuis leur
naissance jusqu'à ce qu'ils sachent
marché et quand les enfants sont
capables de marcher on compare
l'activité musculaire qu'ils avaient
dans ces mouvements là avec l'activité
qu'ils ont en marchant pour essayer de
mieux qu enfin de voir s'il ya un
contrôle moteur commun entre ces
différents mouvements et des recherches
possibles grâce à une équipe qui entoure
la jeune doctorante des étudiants et des
chercheurs plus expérimentés comme sa
directrice de thèse caroline teulier qui
travaille sur ce projet depuis une
dizaine d'années elodie a fait sa thèse
sur des enfants sains pour comprendre le
fonctionnement du mouvement chez le tout
petit et la bourse real c'est pour aller
voir comment ça se passe chez des
enfants qui ont des difficultés motrices
et le but du jeu est évidemment à terme
du coup c'est proposer des solutions
pour aider les enfants qui ont des
déficiences motrices la bourse d'un
montant de 15 mille euros permettra à
l'équipe d'acheter des électrodes à la
taille de ses petits patients
elodie in keynes présentera sa thèse en
la jeune yvelinoise espère poursuivre
ses recherches à l'étranger